ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi e
domenica quindi siamo su è più distratto
ragazzi oggi ciò dei capelli che sono
inguardabili ma chi se ne frega e your
self mi fai male detto per dora
l'esploratrice di candie's cazzo come
come casa fatto alzai con la forza ma
come cazzo fatto l'idea d'accordo ok
perfetto non era o scassato tutto dice
vorrei che t'è capì che non ci riesco si
trova nelle sbatto le balle
vai a bonn mica che salta un palco l'aia
devo pensarci prima fare il tuffo
bombara cosa che mi riesce troppo bene
cifre o cos'è sta roba
zombie defense and press ap non l'ho
letto [ __ ] stanno arrivando non ho
capito che cazzo devo fare una cosa non
ho ciak così addio
non aspettate sto chiusa oggi oh ciao
ragazzi quanto d'oro fare fuori i nomi
jackie così mi piace mi piace troppo tra
l'altro naga sembra quasi che le che
addio sputa una gamba una gamba
sexyssima mi scusi dal telepass sì
allora si lascia la sbarra ragazzino
questo aspetto il nuovo telepass ragazze
panta tratto cosa fa quello gioca a
calcio con la testa di nonno ciak
c'era un dildo lungo lungo che monet
essere più forte di un dock che volevo
tutti quanti massacrare è un bel giorno
sorriso schiacciare è qui che cazzo
ragazzi ci sto prendendo il gusto è
fantastico per un altro seduta si pensò
dicevo se avete notato
ho aumentato il sangue cioè nel senso
adesso si vede di più non devi fare
lobbying mi dispiace per genti è malato
e quindi lo devi sostituire tu vai e
randy mistero nonno non ho mai fatto un
rock swing conta qui liberino farmi fare
figure di merda ha capito tutto ragazzi
e un po sordo non ci sente perdonatelo
allora non lo so che sei un po sordo e
non ci senti quindi ti perdono devi
arrivare alla fine ce la puoi fare
grazie a chi riesce a fare i rock swing
cioè un degno avversario per edita
iandolo dabul by pressing spacebar per
dodici secondi to win
l'ho letto meta inglese metà italiano ma
vabbè non indossare 12 secondi su sta
roba
si accettano scommesse scrivete sì o no
nei commenti se pensate che io ce la
possa fare non ho tanta fiducia in me
stesso ma ci provo
3 2 1 ma magari devo aggrapparmi anche
se non volo come un [ __ ] tanto son
volate lo stesso come un [ __ ] chi è
che aveva detto sì nessuno perché
nessuno ci aveva creduto effettivamente
ma io ce la farò io c'ho la pochi ok va
bene non è esattamente un gioco per
bambini questo ce la devo fare
[ __ ] allora fermo fermo mio dio
ragazzi sotto vincendo sto vince insomma
troppo forte sono troppo forte e il toro
che che voglio me e non io che cavalcano
e c'è anche la gnocca che vi regalano in
omaggio che fest pensa veloce ragazzi
questo è fatto apposta per me che mi
vengono subito ed è geniale quindi ci
prova allora la mia idea è banana non
era esattamente quella giusta vero devo
che cazzo devo fare quei ragazzi
qualcuno mi spiega che dovrei fare il
suo livello non ho capito
sono vivo suo arrivo sono ancora vivo no
giovi fare ed io diciamo così fatta cioè
ragazzi è di assurda l'erede di superman
non ce n'è
non ce ne vai a dimora o mio dio ma che
cazzo fatto
spike partisi michael padani io brutto
stronzo tienimi tienimi figlio tienimi
veri di non mollarlo o niente
chiaramente allora brutto stronzo di
merda leva finito ragazzi sarà
impossibile finire un livello così ma
prima o poi ci devo riuscire cioè ho il
pene di luke ho il pene di fiocchi che
vecchiaccio c'è finito [ __ ] come
ho fatto a morire
ce la posso fare con la testa la testa
ha vinto però io che devi saperlo sei un
bambino inutile non servi a una mazza
non servi a niente non so che cosa ti
hanno messo a fare perché sono
gravissimo anche da sola vai così
grandissimo michele salto acquapazza si
ambulanza rojos lander cos'è sta roba
non a un altro livello con l'accusa
blender seguite ribeiro cmax 23 ma che
non funziona una sega non so come mai
spero che riesce così no aspettate un
attimo chiesto tizio grosso si chiama si
chiama rosa mi fa molto piacere se
sentirò gio vedì raccogliere le pagine
perché è di si contanto c'è
un'espressione troppo intelligente cazzo
devo riuscire a trovare le pagine siamo
a una
ok lo slider inizia a farsi vedere
ragazzi c'è non lo so se fa paura non
penso perché cazzo a livello di happy
meals però vi giuro che è fatto da dio
non ho mai visto ok forse un po di
strizza la mente se devo essere sincero
va bene non sarà mica lo slider man
armarmi prima [ __ ] ragazzi e non è
normale che un livello su happy meals
sia così a non è successo niente chami
stato nomi sta prendendo per il culo
quando quando mi copro non succede nulla
e quando l'ho mica una porta di quella
il certificato medico per il ginocchio
distrutto me lo paga lui vero ragazzi mi
sto sfracellando una gamba fuori a rifar
così c'è ve lo dico sta diventando sta
diventando brutta la situazione non va
che poi non spunta quella [ __ ]
mi ha rotto i cogl arriviamo al finale
di sto li vello che denuncio chi l'ha
creato perché non ha senso il ginocchio
del mio avvocato
no veramente l'avvocato del mio
ginocchio vi farà sapere mi sono confuso
fantastico flander me mi rende
dislessico
a sei vivo non tasto prato che cazzo
succede ucciso lo slider man mio dio che
caso successo cioè lo slider man ha
tentato di stuprare mie ma io ho
stuprato lui è stato è stato il
contrario fantastico raga la prima volta
che ammazzò lo slider man 99 per cento
imposti vorrei avere un si riesca a
battere il mio record di 2 secondi e
mezzo ma vabbè mancato di centrare pure
il buco impossibile mio dio so se sono
ancora vivo
sono ancora vivo nonostante un arpione
del pene abbiamo finito la un'ora e
mezza se ce la fai grandi
45 secondi per finire un cazzo di
livello ai talk to you sure vai così
devo sopravvivere anche in questa devo
andare così fatemi capire dovrei
riuscire a sorpassare un arpione che mi
spara e questo l'obiettivo come già fece
ragazzi sembra facile ma impossibile vi
dirò grande è stata finale ma ce l'ho
fatta anche in questo le 18 e stato
fantastico comunque bungee bungee
jumping questo non è esattamente bungee
jumping con la corda giusta ma vabbè
chissene frank josè nel cestino alain
eccessiva e così da buttare direttamente
sit in job cos'è sta roba devo fare tipo
spider man
vai così impenna come si deve mio dio
ragazzi come saltare da un grattacielo
all'altro e dove la parcheggiamo la vita
risi parcheggiata ragazzi facciamo che
livello che mi avete dedicato perché ho
visto che ne sono sfruttati un miliardo
di falli sheikh ragazzino visti i
livelli la volgia fatto uno simile ed
era uscita una cosa bruttissima
non lo so che cazzo può uscir fuori lo
sapevo lo sapeva e così se non lo sai
che si sta bevendo una birra mentre mi
guarda fuori il decerebrato per strada
va bene così ciao nonno parli un po di
birra stronzo ma che belle scarpe che ho
trovati in giro me le porto a casa hanno
aspettate ma sono mie ragazzi visto
robbie sto rubando una gamba da solo non
si sa perché è di mia proprietà mica mi
sembra uno di quei cani che si
rincorrono la coda non si sa perché
pirlo che è mangiato fagioli e dista il
momento perché c'è aria dentro di te non
lo so vai così la gamba ha vinto non
ancora però ce la posso fare
di 150 secondi per un livello di merda
enrique rain per fa vj by superjet
marjah che ti chiami così amico mio vedi
cambiare atteggiamento perché partiamo
malissimo comunque vado che un babbo
natale quest'anno tanti look e meloni
per natale soldier goldberg fa vj cos'è
sta roba devo fare fa vj cerca di fare
gol
va bene fratello ci provo
ma di quanto cazzola mancata o ragazzi
devo far gol è più forte di me è più
fatto di meglio di moscardelli e veniva
e che fa cenno me fantastico djokovic a
bologna un saluto a tutti i cuori di
bologna facciamo per la previdenza ai
veniva che in pochi infatti j fantastico
se anche gli orchi riesce a volare poi
fai anche tu sei un finto se anche young
and the shak a gare posso farlo anch'io
ragazzi
potete fare tutto sono falliti in poche
parole mai così ai ragazzi io non vorrei
farvi notare come diavolo è piuttosto
livello c'è ma che posizione è questa
cosa è il new kamasutra 2.0 fatemi
capire ai ragazzi concludo più
l'episodio questo era il 24 quindi tra
un po non il prossimo comunque i
prossimi ci sarà un episodio speciale ma
non vi spoiler o nulla non che ragazzi
come solito sei video è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
trovate nella descrizione serve siete
felicity iscrivetevi ricci vediamo il
prossimo vinto bei ragazzi